shiver to me timbers gang we got a hot
new merch drop that's live right now
over there at Ru garbage.com pick
yourself up a t-shirt or a Zippo style
lighter and you can get your ticks there
too it's your One Stop Shop for
everything ayg yeah gang we got a few
shows left on the first leg of the tour
we're coming through Florida we got a
few tickets left in Tampa then we got
Dania Beach Florida we got Raleigh North
Carolina we got Louisville coming up we
got Cleveland and Columbus get those
tickets these shows are selling out
we'll see you out there gang we love you
are you garbage.com welcome so another
exciting Edition
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at tudies in a new edition
baby if you're stopping by use the side
door she's upstairs stretching her legs
okay we're spreading them however you
want to look at it my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he's an international
businessman and he's my best pal in the
whole wide world give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan hey what's up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate the view subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are of cooking and
obviously the greatest gosh darn website
of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage baby
where the magic happens where the rubber
hits the road check it out gang over two
bajillion hours of content over there
keeping me in Tober loans lately I tell
you that patreon's all right how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones Works to
twos the threes and the fours he crosses
the t's and he dots the eyes and Now
ladies you can get a little peek at him
on Adobe cam there he is give it up for
T-Bone discrepancies Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes we got the
good homie in the Edition man I shared a
hotel room with this guy so you know
he's down
man that hotel room must have stunk
yikes dominoes and athlete's foot
but gang the long hair ain't lying we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today his
family at this point as we say he's out
here in the new edition and he has a
brand new special out right now on his
YouTube page called Daddy give it up for
the one the only Jeremiah
did you get that before or after the
special
are you garbage if you make your own
shirt with your own special on it to
come on are you garbage I mean that's a
pretty nice shirt right it's kind of
from the future a little bit it's from
the yeah
that looks like you joined a cult dude
that's got a little bit of [__]
that's got a little Pizzazz though she
just beat up Marty McFly Junior
Burlington Coat Factory t-vice shirts
discontinued for sure definitely bought
it with a gift card kind of a shirt yeah
did you get it did it was it like that
or did you have it made I had this made
really yeah it's a good man you think he
was in a TJ Maxx it was like no [__]
way no no way dude I can't believe I
found this this is fate man data looks
good congratulations oh thank you very
much excited for you we were hanging out
there in Austin a little bit with you
yeah uh good to see you here at hoodies
what were you saying about this
mukbanger what are you talking about
okay my mind almost blew out of my head
when I found out that you have never
heard of a mukbang before
[Laughter]
have you ever heard of a mukbang before
I've heard of it but I don't know if I
know all the I think I know it through
you okay we need to do the next time I'm
on can we do an inaugural are you
garbage mukbang better believe it it's
gonna be amazing we're gonna get our
trashiest Foods possible we you can
order a bunch of stuff either from a
fast food restaurant or it can be from
childhood memories of of stuff maybe
I'll have some homemade white trash
recipes that I'll bring from Kansas City
and Iowa from back in the day okay we'll
bring it in we Feast on it review it
tell the the viewers about it it'll be
awesome so what is it just a smorgasbord
of
trash food a huge amount of food it can
be anything it can be any kind of food
but people review and it's like mass
quantities of food okay okay and you
review it you review it you tell the
people what what it tastes like you like
it man
what are we doing yeah
some guy walks of pizzas not now I think
it's the wrong floor sir
um
what would be some of your trashy
recipes from from back home uh well
fricassee I've never heard of that I
just saw it in Fargo what is it I don't
know I thought you would know you're the
Midwest guy no no
um have you ever heard of a pizza boat
Foley's the first mate baby let's go
my family came over on a pizza boat I
it's a boat you need me on we didn't
land on Papa John's Papa John's landed
on us the Sea of marinara part of the
Red Sea of marinara it's so good what's
a fox of pizza boat so I I never thought
I'd have to answer that question
uh it's basically a pizza yeah on a
water leak suit I mean it goes all the
way back to Christopher Columbus the
need of the paint of the Santa Maria and
the pizza
that was an hour behind them yeah yeah
it's like oh I'm feeling sluggish for
some reason yeah it's uh it's a French
bread loaf okay that you cut in half
okay and the bottom half looks like a
boat uh-huh I mean in loose terms for
sure I'll give you that no you can you
can get inside this boat okay and then
you you have your your homemade uh
marinara sauce that you put on it okay
and then sometimes you put either
hamburger meat or sausage and then
pepperoni you put it in the oven and it
takes about 10-15 minutes to a crisp you
got yourself off a pizza boat have you
ever had a stromboli skateboard
get me the meatloaf tub yeah take us
from Molly put wheels on it throw a
kickflip yeah
um what are your thoughts on Stromboli
by the way you strumble and do you have
any on you I like strumble yeah what's
your what would you say your two what
you too because my favorite soup no what
is your favorite soup though why we're
on it well one of my favorite soups my
mom makes a 15 bean soup it's pretty
good has 15 beans in it so 15 kind of
beans 15 different kinds of beans I
don't even know there's that many man I
don't know she's counting there's so
many different kinds of beans damn yeah
it was just 15 beads in the hole oh no
he's got a [__] Pizza yeah I'm a
pontoon Pizza talk about natural
selection if you get a bean you live for
another couple days
nothing
because that would be the hearty part of
the soup oh that was the thing if it was
just 15 beans like you know the French
how they put little toys in the cakes
and stuff like that around New Year's
Eve sure all right whatever anyway
Stromboli we're talking about here
Stromboli mukbang coming soon
uh clam chowder chili
um uh like a crepe block soup sometimes
yeah Jewish deli soup yeah yeah creamer
made remember I got crepe block going it
misses uh whatever her name was yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah well for yeah I mean
you eat very shitty for your you have a
you know a boyish figure too if I might
say he keeps it tight yeah Toby and I
did share a room uh very romantic
Upstate New York yeah that wasn't that
long ago either yeah yeah and he uh he
made fun of me because uh I was running
in place in in bed
but when you sleep before I wind down do
you remember this yeah like under the
sheets he was like like rubbing his legs
together dude rubbing your legs together
I understand I don't have to burn some
calories or something well the sheets
are cold so you guys
you gotta generate some friction down
here sleeping like a goddamn caveman
like he was trying to make a dick fire
yeah I was like Fred flintstoning I had
in the sheets I rubbed my feet together
as I fall asleep like if I'm laying on
my side I'll rub my opinion it releases
mustard gas
everybody hit the deck
okay yeah huh did you guys get takeout
did you get something ordered into the
room we just ate a lot of dominoes box
in there somewhere it just a lot of
stuff at the club right yeah Comedy Club
food a lot of chicken thandies
and then there's like a diner that we
went to got like milkshakes at or
something like that on a big late night
milkshake guy really yeah yeah do you
work out what's the workout regimen
looking like because you tag Us in
videos that you eating you know 500
Doritos
how old of a fella are you by the way
34. damn and you still got the
metabolism like that it's starting to
it's starting to dip a little bit really
yeah yeah I gotta I gotta be mindful
because uh when I started eating too
much started getting little titties okay
yeah so I keep you around titties at
teddies
uh the little guy your son he's eating
solid food now he's everything yeah yeah
and he gets he gets after it oh yeah
he'll eat something like he'll eat spicy
stuff because he'll eat spicy stuff
he'll eat Takis and different stuff like
that and he'll he got a baby eating
Takis That's crazy dude you're gonna
take him away
[__] child's Protective Services who
gave this baby flaming hot Cheetos he
loves them but he's over there the
doctor he's like he's eating like like
hot chips and stuff smoking Black and
Milds he doesn't but he doesn't he likes
it but he doesn't know like he like his
limit so he just keeps eating him he
goes
and they'll put another one in his mouth
I'm like all right guys where it's
coming yeah he's like this tastes good
though
those takis are tough to stop man once
you open that bag you're in for a long
they're addicting good well I like the
Trader Joe's ones more there so dude
yeah so good well we we know you do you
know you do have a palette of a you know
a dirt bag for sure which we respect but
how do you go the other end do you ever
go out for like a real nice dinner any
other high-end estate something nice you
in the lake house what's a date night
looking with you and the you and the
misses well you're gonna give us your
last one what was the last date this is
gonna be bad it was probably Cheesecake
Factory or something like that which you
know I didn't experience until probably
a little more recently A couple of years
ago probably it's fantastic all right
dude nice in there it's pretty clean the
venues are endless we call the the brown
bread chocolate bread ooh chocolate
bread it's so good chocolate good we
always say yeah I know dry or something
that's pump for nickel but they're like
can we get more of that chocolate bread
over here and how much are your pizza
boats yeah okay she's got tonight out
what do you get a cheesecake you guys
share a couple that's all right it's
nice
um yeah we'll we'll share maybe like an
appetizer I mean we might go during the
happy hour hello
get some half price menu items and stuff
like that yeah I like it but it's like
the mac and cheeseburger there is really
good what
what
okay it's really good never when I see
such a day I didn't even know there was
a battle it's mac and cheese infused
with the burger I I feel like there's
some sort of Dorian Gray thing where the
food you eat makes fully fatter yeah
well something happens there's a
wormhole right here you eat a couple of
spaghetti burgers
in a month is traveling via my nose
well you [__] you and your uh the lady
will you guys share food like is it you
go get this and share or is it you got
yours we like doing no I like always
like even with friends all I like doing
family style where gentlemen like pick a
couple good memories split it down the
middle pass it around that's the way to
go I'm anti that why yeah why I want the
dish I ordered you can take every day
something's yours maybe but I want the I
want the whole I feel like I'm missing
out if I get to have a little this a
little of that I wanna I wanna finish my
plate and go I I've eaten all I wanted
to eat a weird guy we shared an app at
Perry's the pork chop bites
do we want to get into that you had your
own appetizer and you jumped on mine as
well if we're being honest and I was
skimped a little bit I had like two
piece two little bites
like he's over there eating like a Cobb
salad you want some of this oh my God
what did I get I can't remember okay if
you pay for the tab or the bill whatever
are you offended if somebody takes home
their leftovers no no I think we talked
we talked about this with Bobby Lee I
believe and I think we would have talked
about it when the four of us went out to
the diner he gets picked he gets Fury
Bobby will get pissed he refuses to let
you do it I used to go on the road with
him for years and he does he want to
take him home no he does he goes you're
taking my money home that's what he
that's how he feels yeah you're just hey
you're taking my 11 worth of your crab
cakes yeah so just if you don't finish
it you leave it I am I'm a huge
leftovers fan so like when like when you
brought a Bobby like that blows my mind
when people like are weird about that I
don't take leftovers I never have
leftovers I've I've stated this a lot I
think inherently they're trashy I don't
take them because I eat whatever's there
if I like my meal I eat the whole thing
till the point where my stomach hurts
and if I don't like it I don't finish it
Ergo I don't want to take it home with
me for the next day my wife does it my
wife takes the stuff home but I just
never eat it again but if you're paying
does that give you Prima nocta on the
[__] leftovers I respect the power
movement yeah to face throw it in
somebody that's a real thing do you have
the power to when you pay you take
someone's leftovers with you home that's
the move bro yeah that's the power
movement yeah wrap this up yeah yeah
wrap it up uh I'm taking all this home
you do have that right I feel like you
do you technically do technically that
is your property
by The Possession is nine tenths of the
hole I hear yeah huh it's wild but it
doesn't take out in the parking lot and
Smash It On The Ground yeah yeah this
isn't good enough for anybody
huh yeah I mean leftovers are a big
thing it's not my cup of tea typically
but what's the nicest dinner you and
your lady have gone to
you're making me feel insecure right now
and that I should be taking my wife out
the more places because I can't think of
I can't think of what's an anniversary
looking like Norms
hey we're not doing happy hour now we'll
do
um we'll do like sushi or something like
that uh when she's not pregnant okay you
can't yeah you can't do the sushi when
you're pregnant at all the whole time
you can't do sushi you can't do deli
meats yeah something like the nitrates
yeah or turkey and different ham and
stuff like that it's no good for the
baby yeah so I feel like that's recent I
only just started hearing that a couple
of years
there's no way yeah
smoking Bernies the whole time yeah I
assume my mom was ripping heaters while
I was in there she's probably doing it
during labor dude what are you talking
about push Mrs Foley
doc you got a light push this bad
Bastard out
yeah
oh man I'll hold them when I'm done
smoking yeah yeah she puts it down like
walking into a 7-Eleven I'll be right
back
oh that's great what's uh what are what
are you uh what's a vacation looking
like yeah it's tough because we travel
so much we did one that worked out that
was one of my favorite vacations I've
ever gone with my wife I was performing
in uh Honolulu there you go and I took
my wife with me that's great we had uh
family uh watch our baby and we
literally it was just my wife and I went
to Hawaii is this recently yeah in the
summertime nice it was one of the best
trips to stay in Waikiki that's my turf
that's my Island over really yeah big
Honolulu yeah okay yeah Honolulu love it
Oahu the whole island in general yeah
it's some of the best uh fresh fish I've
ever had it was especially Takis I've
ever had
they import them specifically over the
Cheesecake Factory over there is
unbelievable yeah do you remember where
you ate over there
um there were just some like some of the
bowl places
um pokies the pokeballs unbelievable not
a Pokemon Supermarket over there shout
out to food it's so good it was like uh
right around it sounds like your dream
world
Foodland and there I am in Foodland
Foodland top quality operation over
there I'll tell you that yeah the the
Poke bowls and different stuff like that
uh oh and then we also ate at like um it
was a it's a famous uh dying or place
is it yeah is that what it's called
Zippy's or l l lunch
I don't know it's probably Zippy's
Famous Diner it'd be Zippy you know
Honolulu this well yeah my grandson my
girlfriend you think he's [__] with
you yeah no I thought he was yeah I know
I picked up on that oh yeah yeah
oh you're like yeah I love her I love
Honolulu he's like oh yeah dude yeah
dude you'll see that in the playback
yeah it's gonna be great oh yeah yeah oh
do you fatty
yeah Delaware
[Laughter]
no my girl's family's from there
okay cool I love it oh do you love a
walk oh that explains the Hawaiian
shirts you wear
you're Mr Mr Hawaii ah okay the diners
is called Zippy's okay yeah good [__]
yeah really good Korean Fried Chicken in
there is fantastic ooh put a little bit
of eggs yeah and a mac salad I love
those Max hours those are good yeah
T-Bone you're a mac salad guy are you I
am no celery please though I don't like
the crunch I don't know what a mac salad
is what it's called macaroni and
mayonnaise it's [__] fire dude yeah
it's really do they have that everywhere
what you never had that growing up in a
cookie oh macaroni salad yeah I don't
know why I was thinking I was thinking
poke Bowl Max I didn't know where I was
okay you've never had Bernie Mac salad
yeah yeah I ain't scared of you
it's got a DJ with it yeah Bernie Mac
sounds not bad dude
Bernie Mac salad yeah we were doing uh
we were doing uh we were driving through
Oklahoma City where Toby Keith is from
and for some reason we started doing uh
Toby Keith Robinson so Toby Keith lyrics
in Keith Robinson's voice
Toby Keith Robinson that's great
she left me took the kids dummy we never
really perfected it
if we're being honest we love the idea
of the character but we all tried for
about 20 minutes and no line ever I
don't know any Toby Keith lyrics
Toby Keith Robinson's all right
now shout out to Keith all right let's
do something
as you know gang when you sign up for
the old patreon you get your questions
right in the air we have Mr we have Mr
Jared
they got Mr Pizza boat himself
Jeremiah Watkins brand new special out
right now on his YouTube page called
daddy you gotta check it out cause we
love him Kippy hit him what's up okay I
don't like when you deserve that that
hard hard toss over so on that should be
now
all right gang uh let's see this is Matt
The W 10 stakeholder in the organization
shout out to you never have one red have
you already won your family hold on have
you or anyone in your family ever been
in a police lineup
not a police lineup but I've failed a
family member out before
local it was like we're talking about
Federal what are we doing here I was
local I'm not going to say the family
sure yes of course but uh uh it was um
it was like four o'clock in the morning
and I had that's when those calls
usually yeah yeah it's not during
business I had to go to County and uh
because they were in uh they were in a
the like a drunk tank on the shore right
and everybody's making mistakes I had to
get I used to work at a car wash so I
had a guy out front
I want to know what the car wash has to
do with it I had to give them free
Turtle Wax to get them out I did
everything in that car wash what was it
okay everything can I tell you this did
it have a good name to it Waterway yeah
that's pretty good Overland Park Kansas
Waterway what up uh one summer uh a
friend of our family was opening up a
car wash they opened the car wash me and
my buddy both got jobs there
one of my favorite Summers of all time
dude I love this great summer job you're
clean you feel fresh the cars look good
you get a little color you're doing it
in the wintertime crazy oh year round
yeah right yeah [__] that oh yeah that
was I would wash cars when it was 17
degrees outside
if you put it on like the the dolly like
the track system and then once it comes
out on the other side you drive it out
and then that's when you either you know
just wipe it down or detail it depends
on what kind of package they get it's
written on the window I love a nice do
you wipe the I was always the coolest
part of any job in the world to me was
when it rolls off and you slowly walk in
and hop in and it's like you're like
ghost riding the thing oh yeah I was
like man when I when I'm when I'm 16 I
want to be doing that I stay in I stay
in the car for those you can for the
really expensive cars that would make
you do that because they don't want to
[__] they don't want the chance of like
any kind of thing rolling off or but
certain certain cars are so low to the
ground you can't take a Lamborghini
through those automated systems sure
well how am I going to clean my
Lamborghini yeah get somebody was that a
big problem out there a lot of
Lamborghinis coming there would be
people that are like hey and we're like
your car's too rich for us we can't we
can't wash it on it yeah
we had a lady drive through it with a
minivan she was an idiot and didn't
realize that you pull up and you know
put it in neutral she went right through
it shut us down for about two weeks the
owner
freaked out like what the [__] is wrong
with you
yeah yeah they got it's got to be crazy
liability crazy driving other people's
car that whole thing's got to be all
first time drivers I learned how to
drive stick at the car wash
like pulling on like sports cars like
killing it over oh dude I would see them
through the window and they would get so
heated when they'd hear me killing their
car I'm like
okay let's talk about indochino baby
Indochina let's talk about wedding
season coming up you got to look fresh
you're gonna be dropping money on gifts
you're going to be dropping money on
hotels do yourself a favor pick yourself
up a suit that doesn't break the bank
baby with a custom fitted suit from
indochino you can look like a million
bucks without draining the bank account
yeah you know what I'm saying fantastic
you got to play it smart you can
customize every detail of your suit
shirt dinner jacket whatever you want
stunning colors beautiful beautiful
stuff yeah they got stores you can go
into you can do it online as well you
get your exact measurements you create a
suit that fits you and your style you
customize the fabric little the lapel
shape add a monogram whatever you want
um you check out indochino's custom
fitted shirts and Casual Wear you'll
have an entire personalized wardrobe for
the whole the whole whole season baby
there you go RSVP knowing you got the
perfect look all wedding season from
indochino go to indochino.com and use
code garbage uh to get 10 off any
purchase of 399 or more baby there you
go they come correct and you get to wet
your beak a little bit baby that's
indochino i n d o c h i n o.com promo
code garbage one more time indochino.com
promo go garbage do it
Kip how about manscaped Oh you mean the
best in the biz manscape this summer's
coming up you know what the birds do in
the summer they get everything all
cleaned up down there you don't want to
look like the uh the hippie from the 70s
as you're rolling around the beach in
your little uh banana it looks like you
look you got a goddamn woolly mammoth
down there do yourself a favor get over
to manscape pick up that lawn mower
4.0 all included in the performance
package 2.0 but you're gonna get the
waterproof coolest body trimmer you're
gonna get the weed whacker 2.0 which is
perfect for doing the years the nose
hair all that kind of stuff you got to
keep it tight guy and manscape's got you
covered yeah you can refresh your balls
with the crop revive or ball toner baby
got mine looking dizzy the crop
preserver ball deodorant whatever you
need uh to make this summer the best one
yet manscaped has an awesome deal for
our listeners as they always do you get
20 off in free shipping with the code
garbage at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code garbage
at man escape.com trim your testicles
with the besticles manscape.com promo
code garbage do it baby now back to the
show I was a valet for a summer and
that's how I learned
it was at a car dealership guy would
bring in it and they were like hey we
have to teach you how to drive stick
because I didn't know yeah so somebody
next door like next car that comes in
sick just take it in the back and burn
up the [__] out of it
hey that's how you learn
shouldn't have been driving to Scion man
I don't know what to tell you so I took
tips from the car wash
to bail this family member out because
and it was literally it looked like I
had just gotten off shift at a strip
club because it was all one and so I
literally it was a couple hundred
dollars in ones that I put a stack like
to get my family member out I respect
that yeah I want to say what age we
talking were you uh I was probably like
17 uh probably uh more like 18 or 19.
were they younger or older uh the person
who I was bailing out yeah they were
older okay yeah that's a good kid right
yeah yeah yeah yeah you definitely got
it thanks buddy yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
pay you back
huh uh I think I think so I don't think
so yeah be out there like dog to Bounty
Hunter yeah chasing them are we going to
Denny's now what are we doing yeah
I got the bond on him he's tracking him
down
all right Jeremiah Watkins is
um this is one this one's from IB also
10 new 10 shareholder haven't had one
Reddit is it garbage if you've ever
played someone or not is it garbage if
you've ever played someone under
citizens arrest
[Laughter]
is that a real thing Toby give that a go
I think we might have talked about this
years ago or it could be wrong it wasn't
hard feelings or something I think you
can
there has to be some sort of like you
can't do it for like speeding or
something right it's got to be some
level of like like a big like a violent
crime or something something like that
like yeah I think you had to like see it
in the act
like it's coming down yeah that's it
that's my collar I think yeah if
somebody was on like if you see like a
person plane or something yes like and
they're like trying to hold up the plane
I think you can if you get them down to
the ground you're under citizens yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
would you step in if somebody was if
somebody was acting up on an airplane
not like a terroristic threat but like a
drunk guy maybe or would you just fall
back somebody that was if they were
being belligerent to uh like the the
flight attendants and like oh you gotta
because there was a guy not that long
ago it was a couple weeks ago that they
had to make an emergency Lane that the
guy got up and had a fork in his hand or
a knife or something and he was like
threatening to stab the the flight
attendant a bunch of dudes stood up in
[__] house this guy yeah and he got
the seatbelt extender wrapped around
your head for the rest of the flight
yeah would you would you step in depends
how tired I am
it depends it depends like hey excuse me
uh I'm trying to listen to my Enya right
now and fall asleep
it's obviously proximity if you're like
eight rows back and someone's yelling
it's like that's impossible oh excuse me
like three people have to if you gotta
win those seats you're jammed up yeah by
the way your cover's blown there's no
way you can sneak attack sometimes the
flight attends to get mad at you like
all of a sudden you're escalating well
I'm always a window guy so right away
plausible deniability right away exactly
love to help you out but I'm jammed up
listen I got the tray out yeah I think
that like it'd almost be more annoying
for me to be like excuse me excuse me
excuse me I have to go uh help with this
altercation that's going on right here
he can beat up just go back yeah yeah
you sit down there not end well excuse
me excuse me
I promise this will be the last time we
go to the bathroom watch the citizens
arrest story all right private persons
may only arrest those offenders who are
in fact guilty of any offense so you got
to be real certain that they're the damn
that's what I think it's like in the
moment like you see someone steal
someone's purse and you try you gotta
have a bulletproof case strip them up or
something exactly uh can you get in
trouble if you falsify citizens arrest
oh I'll get on that in a second uh but
uh the practice dates back to Medieval
England and the English common law in
which sheriffs encourage ordinary
citizens to help apprehend law Breakers
that's old school [__] right there yeah
that's a [__] lazy Sheriff
right now
damn
wow yeah that's pretty uh how you always
wanted that so you always want to do
that you know Jam someone else I would
just say I'm a cop at that point instead
of saying citizens arrest then I'd
arrest you why [__] impersonating an
officer not if I'm saving lives oh I
don't know put me on the force hey guys
thank you Deputy for today or something
ah that'll be all right
a couple of regulators riding through
um get some nickel all right let's see
here this is from Sean uh
as a kid you ever go out to get
something to eat with your buddy and
their dad
and the and he only gets food for
himself and his friend because you're
not my kid whoa God damn wait say that
slower yeah there's an error in it
that's why I stumbled you ever go get
something to eat with your buddy and
their dad and they only get food for
himself and he and your friend because
in quotes you're not my kid that's a
shitty dad right there because that was
the whole fun of going out with your
buddy's parents you knew they were
[__] paying yeah they're footing the
bill yeah what do you mean will you buy
your kids friends talkies or is that
just for them uh yeah it's gonna happen
it's good
if you take it if when your son gets
older you guys he's got a buddy over
come on we're going to get pizza you're
not [__] sending him a venmo request
now what if it's your son and his
stepbrother from the marriage that is
not happening with you
wait say that slower that's real trashy
by the way is this your family no no no
uh like I there's got to be situations
out there where so it's your son and his
his mom's other new brother
wait that is connected to a different
dad but is he now your technical stepson
no no so you what you're saying is
they're they're friends and and they're
going out but like you're like you and
let's say you and your wife got divorced
your wife remarried yes
um that guy had it that guy had a kid
from another marriage too I mean yeah
you're the adult you gotta what you're
gonna ice the kid put my foot down on
that go find me your dad
no you're not I ain't the one all right
go get a job go work in a car wash do
something earn some money get yourself
some goddamn pizza money that's
something that would really bother my
dad that would have pissed my dad off if
he would if he would know something like
that I remember one time when I first
saw the Landscaping at this place uh
these two guys it was the end of the day
they were my bosses they I didn't have
any money on me and they went into
7-Eleven and didn't ask if I wanted
anything and I was starving and they
didn't say a word they got in the car we
drove home and somehow it came up in
conversation and I was like yeah they
didn't get him anything my dad [__]
hated those guys really yeah yes they
hated them well co-worker jobs like
camaraderie when you're when you're
under someone else's care it's kind of
like you're lumped in with them to take
care of their kids that's that's how you
gotta look at it I know you're a good
dad you would definitely get the kids
stuff no we wouldn't you wouldn't no
[__] him yeah right well I don't know
why you're taking it so serious we're
clearly doing it for like your eyes
before also you said you were working
that was different yeah you should have
had money you probably blew it all on
drugs or something you idiot I wouldn't
buy the fat drug addict food either if
he was blowing his money huh hey buddy
you're stuck with money I mean if you
have a job you should have money you're
under arrest
I would buy you something but this is
contributing to the problem yeah I don't
want to be an enabler
that's good I got the nitty-gritty on
citizens arrest go ahead lay it on me
all right if your Citizen's arresting
somebody and you [__] them up you break
their nose you break their arm or
something like that you rough them up I
could do this the hard way or the easy
way yeah yeah you're in the clear what
what oh man I so just wanted to punch
fully right in the face I think so if
you're gonna cold [__] someone just yell
citizens arrest right before you wait
that's that that's if they're convicted
right yeah yeah well I would just if I'm
in a bar fight and some guy's like I'm
gonna [__] you up oh God that's a
terroristic threat citizens arrest and
nail them wow
buddy kippy's beating the system over
here all right all right you only have
one hour to detain the person
if if if one hour in one minute the cops
haven't shown up yet you gotta let him
go that's an awkward conversation
oh one hour and then it turns into
kidnapping right
yeah hey man I'm sorry about that I'm
sorry things got crazy dude things are a
little weird you seem like a great guy
try your free pizza Domino's yeah 30
minutes
that sucks at that moment got the best
of me that sucks
well my buddy was saying in Texas he uh
he caught a guy stealing his car and he
held him and called the cops and like
held him and then because the cops just
never showed so I just had to let him go
oh and he just like let him go and he
ran away let him off with a warning talk
about a weirdo don't let me catch you
back here talk about a weird Walk of
Shame just like looking back I mean like
are we still we good now yeah you
definitely run away yeah you do a couple
of steps in a turnaround to take off
yeah
and to get you dirty no good uh it's a
good one right there
um all right let's see this is true this
is from Matthew is it garbage or post a
message on social media wishing your kid
or family member a happy birthday and
include a link to their cash app venmo
or PayPal
I don't like the
I don't I don't I don't love it
I kind of it depends on who that's for
though that might be for like an aunt
you know like it's not towards just like
the random friend on Facebook type thing
it might be like hey you know if your
aunt or somebody goes oh it's Toby's
birthday I'd love to send them you know
20 bucks for a beer it's always weird
when people put it like on social media
like hey it's my birthday here's my
venmo I wasn't gonna send you anything
anyway yeah what are you [__] why are
you putting it out there that's crazy
yeah that's I don't even really like the
public birthday
the older I get the more I'm like maybe
it's better that nobody knows yeah no
[__] yeah that's half your security
question right there halfway through the
Vault you kidding me yeah how they gotta
figure out the name of my pet and I'm
screwed uh if I could Jam me up I do
kind I don't hate I know they catch [__]
but like you see on a car like hey
bachelorette party send the bride a beer
I kind of respect that I kind of like
I'm a partier that's a good time that's
fun it's exciting I'll get I'd give you
that yeah [__] that hoe
[Laughter]
oh that's fun if you want to you know
people are celebrating something I kind
of get I kind of get that I can't stand
the bachelorette party
yeah get invited to a lot of them
I just can't go on one more Bachelorette
yeah I got the cowboy hat out and
everything
a couple of guys trying to hook up with
the girls oh you got Foley a tough break
I don't know if you remember yeah
I don't know
I'll buy her a beer I guess any of that
stuff is is weird so if your aunt
if your aunt says hey I'm Toby's Aunt
it's his birthday here's his venmo
that's a little bit different yeah
somebody else's behalf yeah yeah that's
it that's your antler hey so-and-so's
graduating or something yeah if you do
it it's bad but I think it's like hey
happy birthday if you were like 18 or
whatever hey happy birthday to Toby your
mom posted what's your you know
Instagram handle you can go buy whatever
if someone were ever to publicly be like
Toby's venmo is
and then a bunch of people send me cash
I would hate that
you're being everybody send them
requests don't send them cash send them
requests
that's evil right there oh
Danny looking a dick you don't ship the
cat
said that out
some guy hit me up on time for like
eight bucks and he's like hey it's worth
a shot
I forget probably not
my homie went viral on LinkedIn venmo
requesting CEOs for a year's salary
that's good that's like 125 000 memo
request wow I respect that can you go
viral on LinkedIn he did not 100 sure I
understand what that is uh yeah on
LinkedIn viral is 10 people
[Laughter]
he has a lot of connections on here
that's where that's where you post your
jobs right what your title is yeah not
on LinkedIn
yeah man you're not only come on
yeah who's gonna hit me up hit me up
anybody it's like monster.com right no
no it's like where you put like your
it's like Facebook professionals yeah oh
really you connect with other people you
can link up with other fat asses
you've been doing that professionally
for a while hey I've really seen you've
fallen into your stride the past 18
months
ah you're getting busted
citizens are up here and take this your
forehead's too big
taking you downtown buddy oh man we're
having a good time with all J dubs
uh do you have any nicknames growing up
uh uh Jay watt J dub
um Wild Thing
who called you a wild thing uh my soccer
team for years that was a wild thing
really really oh yeah why'd you make
their heart sing or something what's
going on oh come on hello it's something
crazy uh I was hit up or something I was
uh State ranked as a goalie as a kid
really yep and I was the only kid that
uh coaches and teams that would see at
my age that would completely lay out to
block goals you're a string bean too
yeah kids were too uh well this one was
fat uh kids would uh be too afraid to
lay out or to challenge uh like in the
in the Box basically I would come out
full force and I would jump on the ball
get kicked in the face I'll just make
sure that I was blocking goals you know
that's good Wild Thing yeah it's all
right yeah we had a bulldog in high
school Kim shot I'm calling the Bulldog
he had just one wrestling he would just
grab you by the top and just [__]
swing away yeah
attack
we're going on the Bulldog he's a nice
guy now he was super strong
make you come quicker than a speeding
bullet
shout out to the bulldog
hey buddy if you're out there call me uh
the one that got away
[Laughter]
summer of my life man yeah you guys are
about to feel real bad he died I'm fine
I'm still feeling pretty good about that
joke they were pretty good riffs yeah
the Bulldog would have loved it yeah the
Bulldog was all right wow good kid oh
God
my head hurts all right
let's see here all right this one's from
Jaden
is it garbage to save your 7-Eleven a
cup your 7-Eleven cups to get a free
refill
yeah what do you what yeah however
no just to play devil's advocate here
if your regular morning routine involves
stopping at 7-Eleven and getting a sodi
or something like your morning routine
okay all right we got to get you on
LinkedIn if you're on your way to work
every day I could see saving the company
going in but when does the refill
technically expire isn't it like from
day to day I don't think ever where were
we what's the one uh Circle K
we were in the middle of wherever you
know what I mean driving up through the
middle of the country and people were it
was like you can buy like a monthly car
oh the big dude wasn't even like a
reusable it was just like those big mugs
are all and you would go in and get your
44 out it was like 44 ounces a day for
like a dollar a day or something like
that yeah so much coffee babe I remember
one of my first this was soda I remember
one of my first roast jokes uh about a
family member that my mom died laughing
but she's like please never repeat this
to any other family members is my aunt
uh she was always hooked up to an oxygen
machine and she um she had a mullet and
she always had like one of those like
Casey's like big mugs of like like pop
issue drink and stuff like that and I
said that she looked like Darth Vader
with a mullet and my mom's like that's
hilarious but please don't say that out
loud again that is a rough one yeah yeah
can't be making fun of your sickly
family members like that yeah
nothing on that yeah
definitely ain't had an oxygen tank I
mean we always had to be real careful
around it yeah and stuff like that well
yeah I mean I mean fire hazard alone you
shouldn't be smoking near a woman with
an oxygen mask
she's had enough she used the smoke yeah
no [__]
yeah that's a tough look
um
all right this one's from Drew is it
garbage you have to order drive-through
fast food from the back seat of someone
else's car
I don't think I've ever did that
ever why in What scenario I guess maybe
they're not paying
uh or maybe it's an Uber or a taxi
Jeremiah you're driving say the four of
us are in a car yeah we're in your car
we're out in L.A we pull up two and in
and out are you handling the ordering
Foley what do you want Toby what do you
want Kevin what do you want you're doing
that right I'll do that or I'll do the
thing where I'm like you can lean over
me in order if it's a very specific
order sure I understand both of that
yeah either got a quarterback or go hey
if you're not just getting a number
three with the transaction yeah I'll do
the transaction sure the the two voices
would bother me it would bother me as an
employee and I would if I was driving
just tell me what you want we're not
screaming at this person
you know unless it is something real
specific I sometimes make my girl do
that I'm like lean over and tell them
because she gets something very specific
at Starbucks yeah and I always [__] it
but from the I mean I like the idea
though of someone being like so health
conscious that they refuse to like
they'll not drive you to the location
but I'm not having any I don't want
blood on my hair exactly exactly so it's
like me driving Foley in the back and
I'm just like you order what you want
that big oh geez hey nothing on that
I'm talking about myself
I do it all the time uh
uh all right let's see here this is from
Justin is it garbage you use lava or
Gojo as your regular soap at home no you
know the lavas it's like it's like
mechanic soap it's great it would be
it's got like a little bit of pink
there's pink stuff
lava is uh lava's orange if I remember
correct yeah pumice in it it has lava
rocks in it I mean that's all they're
doing now with the height with the
high-end [__] anyway by wd-40.
yeah it's like it's for mechanics it's
like so you're not squeaking
I mean my hand soap that I use sometimes
is Ajax
like the for like the dishes yeah that's
all the same soap though I thought you
meant like you just put like putting
like powder like comment that's common
that's common I think there might be
powder I love throwing that up like
LeBron whatever I'm doing dishes are you
guys ready for dinner come on
I love the dude scrubbing the the tub
with Comet oh man you really see it get
clean yeah I love that stuff Ajax is
okay using using dishwashing so that's
all the same yeah who doesn't love that
smell of palm Olive ooh it's good the
green Palmolive this [__] takes me
back it's a little different I love that
[__] but love is okay the high-end stuff
now all has that exfoliating [__] in it
the sugar scrubs and this and that
high-end bars but that's nice was just
ahead of the game why not you're
exfoliating yeah but it's not the the
the the the the issue isn't with the
exfoliating the issues with what the
this the stuff is in fact that goop
that's [__] heavy dude that ain't
that's that's the clean carburetors and
[__] that you should have been washing
your hands after you go to you after you
do number one that's probably a little
garbage to have that as your go-to song
also it's like I don't know if you
recall but the lava you had to like goop
out with your hands and the lid was
never on now I remember lava being a bar
a lava soap no in a bar ours was the the
orange like yeah yeah yeah and if the
Citrus smell was great yeah I wish bar
soaps would just disappear and like wash
places the bar soaps that are like to
like at people's houses that you're a
guest at that yes that you there should
never be it's gross yeah dude there's a
bar there used to be a bar soap in the
in the parking garage it's not too far
like at 7-Elevens and stuff there should
never be sure 100
but I prefer a bar at home
if there was a bathroom like a half bath
downstairs for people to you know to
wash their hands still no bar of course
nobody
you know my my in-laws do which is a
real nice thing they have uh no paper
towels which you know is fought they but
they have a bunch of like you go into
like a nice steakhouse they have a bunch
of towels like washcloths no like to dry
your hands with they're like thicker
they're like thicker paper these are
like they're they're Essentials almost
like a like uh are they reusable or
reusable then you throw them in the
there's like a stack like 12 of them oh
no I'm talking about the things that are
you throw them away no you're talking
about paper towels essentially with a
little bit of a little bit of they're
real thick though they're real nice yeah
yeah no classy this is like a towel that
you would have in like a nice restaurant
like Gallaghers and then you throw it in
the basket but I could get a nice clean
fresh dryer sure I know what you're
talking about yeah someone else's
[__] wet towel what about a hand
towel are you a hand towel somebody
else's house hand towel that hand towel
who knows what's going on with that I
try not to think about it I try not to
all right yeah you can tell try to find
a right spot on it as soon as you put
your hands on you're like ah this has
been here for a while yeah this is fresh
no no you can feel it right away I've
got a I've got a joke about towels in my
special that is yeah yeah it's gross
yeah
that was that I think it was at Ari's
first of all I think I went to R I would
not touch anything I went to pee atari's
and there was already pee in the toilet
like this guy plays it fast it's about
that life dude yeah and then I went to
wash my hands and before I did I looked
around I'm like yeah I'm Gonna Roll the
Dice on this one I'm not drying anything
I'm not touching anything in here Ari
would Upper Deck his toilet just to [__]
with you yeah yeah yeah just to make you
think like did I just [__] in here
what's happening
hmm I mean yeah he is uh he is he is a
Madman uh all right let's see this one's
from Kenny new Florida Bozo never have
one red is it garbage if you're a high
school substitute teacher was in a rap
group and tried to sell us merch in the
middle of class holy [__] I respect it
baby constantly closing
that's tough man how can you let the
kids they would have to lose respect for
you pretty quick there's no more unique
group of individuals than the substitute
teacher I don't know how it is now
but back in the day back in the day they
were a special breed yeah did you have
any like because at times we had like
you would get like the regulars you know
what I mean there was this old guy that
would come in he would complained that
he didn't get paid enough to even get
drunk on that's what he would say every
day then there was like in school like
in building ones that would like fill in
yeah like every day someone would call
out of something and he would you know
jump in did I ever tell you guys about
my geometry teacher named uh Greg Gehrig
I don't think so we called him G squared
and this guy I was I apologize Greg if
you're out there I I tormented this guy
sure I um I took a picture of him in
class oh no it's wild thing
laughs
uh I took a picture of him at class like
like looking straight into my camera
because he's he turned like and I caught
it at the perfect time we talking
disposable camera uh this was a digital
camera okay so I went home and I printed
it off and I I photoshopped her it was
like word at the time I put I heart gray
Gehrig and I had a picture frame belt
buckle and I wore it to school that's
fun and so he saw it and he's like
um Jeremiah could you uh not wear me as
a picture
shut up Greg and I'm like nah I'm good
and I just wore it because then it just
looked like this weird teacher-student
relationship that was that was taking
place
probably got arrested
who knows uh shout out to G squared I
remember we had one same thing was
uh our one teacher had like a nervous
breakdown the like third week of school
so then they had like a sub for a week
another sub for a week it was like when
is she coming back who knows so then at
that point you were getting like a cell
a new sub ever like three to four or
five days so we knew we were like oh we
don't have to [__] do [__] there's
nobody you know that's awesome they're
just in there making sure we don't
[__] kill each other yeah so there
was like no put the movie on and shut up
it was like some busy work and we're
like and then after like the third week
no one's even [__] checking this you
know what I mean we're like [__] this
then we got a guy
who was like he's going to be the new
permanent guy but like he found out
after like two weeks they were like all
right we're gonna stick with like Mr
Lansdown or whatever the [__] his name
was and uh but that point nobody
respected him because we thought he was
a temporary guy right so now he's got a
[__] he came in like like at that
second week when he found out he was
staying for good he came in different
kinds dude slams the door shut everybody
sit down there's like a paper plane
flying and we were like [__] you he's
like I'm not taking that [__] dude and
he caught me [__] catching a heater
on school property I was in my car
technically not I was like on the
parking I'll leave in the parking lot
catching a mean one and uh he pulled up
right next to me and I was like oh [__]
I hit it cars filled with smoke I'm
bumping 50 cents shout out to the Chevy
Lumina
and then he brings me to school the next
day he's like Kevin uh I like made a
joke or something it was kind of one of
those things I'm like let me see what he
said I made a joke in the middle of
class to see where we stood like if he
saw me or whatever he's like I'll be
talking to you after class and I was
like oh [__] can I smoke on you yeah hey
buddy you got a light and he goes uh I
know one things he goes I'm not a cool
guy but I do know one thing smoking is
not cool whoa full-on after school
special I don't know why you're telling
me this dude I don't ever touch the
stuff he's like I heard the 50 Cent
Kevin I knew it was you I knew it was
yeah Richard I try and please yeah
I've told you this before uh Kippy but
Jeremiah we one of our subs in eighth
grade talking Prime Time adolescent
hormone age was a former Playboy model
what yeah she was an actress and a play
and a Playboy model in in Philly
and man
she got after it
did you have any really attractive
something yeah really yeah there's a
couple what age there was one uh I mean
there's one at certain ages when your
hormones are pumping it could be you
know could be the 80 year old lady I'd
still be wrong thinking about it uh yeah
enough beard you know what I mean there
was one in grade school that uh just
huge knockers
that she didn't wear a bra
you never know as kids but I saw it I
saw it like she had huge boobs but she
never wore a bra she never wore a bra
damn yeah kind of Alternative Learning
school did you go oh that's what was
weird this was a like uh like a private
Christian School so like you would think
that somebody would say something to her
but also at the same time they're so
religious that they might be like well
maybe I don't even know how to say it
yeah like they they're not even aware
she might not be even aware that her
body is so big and real like it was yeah
wild pain man that's [__] up yeah he's
like he's like my friend who saw it he's
like it was it was so milky and pure it
was so gross the way he described it was
Christian responses I know I was so good
the pure the purest bosom they were the
viewers gazangas I've ever seen in my
life Supple nipples I've ever seen and
I've only seen my moms
damn yeah no problem
I wouldn't have got anything done
yeah stumbling around the hallway I just
got distracted to myself I mean the
podcast almost ended right there we all
went
give me a minute
uh we got time for a few more here this
is from Drew
um
is it garbage to stay a few days at your
local hotel slash Motel door in a
massive Heat Wave because your air
conditioning at home just ain't cutting
it I respect that very much so yeah I
know you're just vacation yeah hit the
pool why not uh-huh yeah I mean what
yeah exactly why the [__] you do it in
New York sometimes when it's like when
it's like crazy hot and people just
leave they're like I'm gonna go visit
somewhere else I'm getting out of here
yeah I'm going to you know my parents in
the suburbs or whatever it is get out of
town that's classy if anything you got
your you added a new room to your home
oh it's a new Addiction baby take over
come on yeah you get to that hotel room
if you think you think about it if you
go to like a cheap motel it's probably
you know whatever it's
pretty cheap they're always going to run
the AC like crazy you got a maid that
comes in what is it about that
some of those old block units
the rooms are so small and those things
just it drops down to 60 degrees crazy
yeah yeah shout out throw it boys uh
this one's from Drake 10 Lehigh Valley
Hoagie here never have one red is it
garbage if your dad took you out of
school every year to go camp out at the
NASCAR race in Dover for the weekend
also saw my first pair of tits there I
was seven years old
that's a good weekend right there
man that's like a white trash Bar
Mitzvah right there yeah that's all
right
would your parents ever let you get out
of school for like a would you ever do
vacation during the school year my mom
was awesome about she she gave no F's
with the school that we went to she'd
pull us out of school sometimes and
they'd be like why Mrs Watkins are they
sick what's going on she goes no we're
gonna have a fun day today
out to that she would just tell the
principal that we were having a fun day
we would go get McDonald's and just go
to the park and play really yeah she
would it was awesome it was like some of
my best memories from childhood is she
would sometimes come in the middle of
the day she's like we're leaving I'm
like what and then we would go get
McDonald's and we'd go to the park it
was incredible it's gonna make me cry
that's [__] awesome yeah Mickey D's
when you don't see it coming everybody
else is still alive
kids are looking like where are you
going I'm like I guess I'm I guess I
have the car
see you losers later that's why they
call me the wild see you around nerds
see you Greg squared I'm out that's
[__] sick dude yeah damn that's
amazing yeah that's [__] a good time
what a [__] awesome Mom man yeah yeah
what age we talking dude grade school
like up until probably like uh when
school work starts getting more
important sure a little more intense it
was more like she showed up to college
like between yeah yeah we're going
Mickey D's pleasure
all right we gotta wrap it up
oh gang buddy Jeremiah Watkins we love
you to death no special as we said out
right now on the YouTube page call Daddy
what else you want the folks don't know
brother hit them uh Jeremiah stand up on
social media uh both these guys have
done stand up on the spots
on the YouTubes uh check it out we put
out new episodes every other month
Monday at youtube.com stand up OTS and
then Jeremiah wonders and scissor Bros
if you want to follow me I put out a lot
of stuff uh and uh yeah I always love
hanging with you guys this is my first
time in studio we've done a couple rode
ones but this is my first time all right
we did it we did a yeah
in the basement either no he did skank
Fest when we did skank Fest I remember
we did the one in Houston but yeah I
thought you were I could have swore for
sure you were assume the zoom was the
first handy baby old school yeah so the
roots baby I love it yeah awesome man
from Jump Street baby we love you
congrats on a new special can't be what
do you got for him guys we're over the
road uh tickets are on sale get them
we're announcing more cities get those
tickies uh we're adding second shows in
some places some places we're not so if
you snooze you lose love you gang see
you next week peace